looking ahead to the beginning of the
school year with clark county school
district which is august 8th can't
believe it's already here john valardia
is here from the clark county education
association to talk about from the
union's point of view the beginning of
school uh what teachers are dealing with
the last couple of years have been so
challenging with covet and everything
else that's been going on let's just
talk about what the expectations are
from your end for the beginning of
another school year
well we are working with the district to
make sure that we fill these positions
that need to be filled so that
classrooms have licensed professionals
and where they don't they have at least
a competent professional substitute in
place so that we start the school year
as best as possible we're looking to
make sure these schools are safe given a
lot of issues that have emerged just
this past year around the safety issue
the co-vet precautions that the district
had in place in the past they've been
modified somewhat going into this school
year but they're still there because
there might be you know resurgence of
the transmission rate of covet
and then of course we're looking at you
know how do we
try to recover lost education for a lot
of these students that they experienced
during the cove let's we'll touch on a
couple of those things in a moment again
but let's talk about vacancies within uh
the the staffing for teachers across the
district it's been an issue it was
addressed a lot and really was a concern
and a challenge for ccsd at the
especially at the end of last year it
was talked about a lot what is the
vacancy rate right now how short
is ccsd well i think they went into
this school year with
a little over 1400 vacancies okay
and i think the district is probably
close to 91 92
filling those vacancy numbers as of this
moment that we're talking for example
today they have a new higher orientation
with educators
they will continue to hire as the school
year goes on but i think they're
proceeding to fill those vacancies will
they fill all of them when the school
year opens no that's why we'll have a
need for a substitute are you concerned
or should parents be concerned with the
amount of vacancies within the district
i think every parent should be concerned
about what their classroom
is going to look like for their student
whether or not they have a licensed
professional or substitute
i can tell you we've just adjusted the
starting salary
for teachers it's over 50 000 it's made
a big difference in the district's
effort to recruit so we've seen a spike
in hiring so
my message to parents is that you know i
think we're trying to work through the
uh challenge when i say we
you know i represent the teachers but
we're working with the school district
and and trying to accomplish
another major issue that you addressed
uh school safety uh the horrible
situation at el dorado high school last
year we saw the incident at clark high
school desert oasis there have been
issues around the district that's not
necessarily new it's a big district
things happen
just this week the school district
announced the addition of cameras on
buses as a way to sort of help with
school safety issues um
is it enough what else should the
district be doing well if anything ever
happens you'll find somebody who'll say
it's not enough right i think there's
been a big wake-up call that we have to
make sure
that these campuses these buses these
classrooms
have secure environments that are safe
for both educators and students we've
seen a rise of violent behavior in this
school district
and culminating in the heinous crime
that occurred at el dorado i think the
measures that the district is taking
right now are the right ones and it's in
the right direction i think it's not a
light switch solution though i think we
were talking 370 schools 300 000 kids
i think the district is on the path
addressing the high need areas first and
foremost we're comfortable with that is
it is it enough yet no
legislative sessions on the horizon uh
what are some of the priorities for ccea
funding um we
well it's more than as usual the last
legislative session passed a new funding
formula
and it's based on student needs and
equity and it needs to be funded on an
annual basis of 200 million dollars more
and so that's going to be a challenge in
the legislative session if if there's
not resources we can't talk about things
like improving safety things like having
the appropriate staff in these schools
you know we got a big bump with federal
dollars that's what's been paying for
some of this stuff we need ongoing
revenue and most of that comes from the
state so that's a priority for us one of
the ongoing questions as you know with
ccsd when things are of concern
people talk about we should break it up
a lot of the politicians running for
some big offices around the state are
suggesting at the very bare minimum
looking at it
your thoughts on
that long discussed
thought
yeah i mean i don't think it's a well
thought out thought okay i don't think
it's a question of like creating seven
school districts i think it's a question
of let's look at the delivery system
that you have now which is one school
district make sure it's adequately
funded adequately staffed
managed appropriately by administration
and have an effective school governance
model that makes sure that their primary
objective is kids learn and i think
that's where our focus should be
um final question here uh end of the
last school year there's i think there
was a perception in the community about
uh acrimony at ccsd on the board
with administration with teachers
um and that hasn't really gone away it's
been quiet for the last couple of months
it's been summer obviously how would you
describe
just the lay of the land from your point
of view at ccsd right now your ability
to work with dr jarrah and his team to
work with the school board members and
what you're hearing from teachers
heading into this new school year
so i would describe our relationship
with administration as issue based it's
very frank and honest and transparent in
other words we don't try to get into the
politics that might be seen on the
school board with the administration
it's about hey we have vacancies how do
we resolve it we have safety issues how
do we resolve it how do we try to
retrieve lost education as a result of
the covet experience for all these kids
as well as dealing with the challenges
our educators have whether they're
overworked and don't have the
appropriate resources or they themselves
have had some you know mental health
issues because of the stress of covet we
have an honest and i think transparent
issue based relationship with
administration
with the school board trustees i think
that's a work in progress i mean i we've
been advocates since the last
legislative session to look for a fix
where we can have a much more efficient
and competent and student-focused
governing body here we're going to
pursue that
so the the narrative maybe that's out
there of what is happening in the
district and that it's
there's just a lot of problems is it is
that a fair narrative do you think that
the public has the right grasp of what's
really happening at ccsd
i i think the public has a grasp of
problems as they see it or if they're
apparent has the experience and and i'm
not going to challenge what their their
perspective is on it i will say this we
have had in the last several years we've
reorganized the school district into a
decentralized model and learning to what
that means we've gone through two years
of covad and lost education and the
challenges with that we've introduced a
new funding formula at the state level
that tries to provide equity and need
for students that's not properly funded
enough yet and we have a national
shortage of staffing starting with
licensed professionals that's not a
school district issue it's a national
issue it's a state and school district
partnership that's going to be required
to make that you know solution happen
for us so i i think that the bigger
picture i don't think everybody sees
that
my job is to see the bigger picture to
try to find those solutions but i think
what somebody might experience a parent
may experience something happening in
school i'm not going to challenge their
perspective on it i would just add to
her what the bigger picture is fair
enough john relorita from the clark
county education association with school
approaching quickly here in clark county
john good to see you nice to be here
john